will foul and before the ball is inbound
and now they've done that already
the clippers 23 and three this year when
leading by 10
or more points they've led by 16 tonight
these are big free throws right now for
westbrook who's three of nine there
tonight
three of ten westbrook as great of a
game as he's had
23 points nine rebounds 11 assists
played so well defensively if he makes
the free throws this game is over
and he makes one of two and a timeout
taken here
by tyler that's right i can rhyme
they're gonna have to be for they're
going to force the foul but you do not
need to make any drastic decisions
scoring the ball
making the home run play uh throwing out
to a guy that's least timeout took off
those arm sleeves
that's the secret get rid of the arm
sleeves
make the free throw zubats will come
back in
kenar goes to the bench interesting
substitution because canard is such a
good three-point shooter
[Music]
he gets the roll makes them both clutch
free throws there by west